mais les américains méritent une
discussion qu'ils soient civils
pauli nous allons mettre de l'avant un
échange respectueux sur des questions
importantes
commençons par le sujet de la pandémie
la pandémie a coûté cher à notre pays
sénatrice tarissent pas que 8,19 n'est
pas sous contrôle dans la dernière
semaine
john hopkins a indiqué que 31 états ont
eu plus de cas que dans la semaine
précédente
neuf cas ont dépassé des records la
prochaine administration américaine sera
face à un défi d'importance vous faire
en janvier et février
allez vous imposer un confinement allez
vous imposez amende décret pour le port
du mercy ce que vous avez deux minutes
le peuple américain a vu le plus grand
échec de toute administration
présidentielle depuis l'histoire du de
nothing et voici les faits deux cent dix
mille décès dans notre pays dans les
derniers mois 7 millions de personnes
atteints du virus
une entreprise sur cinq fermes et les
travailleurs de première ligne traités
comme des sacrifices grant millions de
personnes qui depuis les derniers mois
ont dû toucher le chauffage le chômage
je vois si la chose
le 28 janvier le vice président et le
président était informé de la nature de
cette pandémie que la conséquence était
mortel que ça se dispute par l'air que
j'allais avoir un impact sur les jeunes
et que ça pouvait être contractés parce
que c'est dans l'air
il savait ce qui se passait et il nous
ne vous en rien dit imaginez si on avait
su le 28 janvier au lieu du 13 mars
ce qu'on devait faire pour se préparer
ils le savaient et ils l'ont caché le
président a dit que ce n'était pas vrai
ils ont minimisé le sérieux le président
a dit vous êtes d'un côté si vous portez
un masque vous êtes l'autre de l'autre
côté si vous ne portez pas un masque et
malgré tout ça aujourd'hui
ils n'ont toujours pas un plan et n'ont
toujours pas un plan les joe biden a un
plan notre plan touche une stratégie
nationale pour le traçage pour les tests
de dépistage pour l'administration du
vaccin pour s'assurer que ça soit
gratuit pour tout le monde ça c'est le
plan de joe biden et deux mois en
sachant qu'elles nous devons contrôler
ce qui se passe et nous devons sauver
notre pays et joe biden est le meilleur
leader pour le faire et franchement ils
ont mérité sur ce monsieur
vice-président pence
plus de deux cent mille américains sont
morts de lakovic 19 depuis février le
tout décès dans notre population et des
plus hauts non le monde entier notre
taux est deux fois plus élevé que celui
du canada cg au groupe de travail sur le
qui-vive 19
pourquoi est ce que notre taux de
mortalité est si haut comparativement à
tous les pays riches de la planète
et j'aimerais remercier la commission
électorale et l'université de l'utah de
nous accueillir
et là c'est la taça russe c'est un
privilège de partager cette estrade avec
vous notre nation a traversé vraiment
des épreuves cette année mais j'aimerais
que le peuple américain sache que dès le
premier jour le président notre homme a
mis la santé de ses concitoyens au
premier plan à vins qu'on ait atteint 5
à des gens qui retournent est la chine
soit dit en passant le présenter
a fait ce qu'aucun autre président
l'avait fait à savoir
il a suspendu tout déplacement
provenance de la chine la deuxième
économie mondiale
maintenant sénatrice jour by day était
contre cette décision
il a dit que cet exil aux formes et de
l'hystérie
moi je vais vous dire ayant été à la
tête du groupe de travail sur le corps
n'a virus et bien cette décision nous a
donné le temps de nous mobiliser comme
jamais auparavant depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale je pense que nous avons
sauvé ainsi des centaines de milliers de
vies car avec ce temps là nous avons pu
réinventer les tests on en a énormément
aujourd'hui on a pu livrer des milliards
de dollars d'équipements de protection
et de soude fait pour notre personnel
médical et même à 20 le mois d'avril on
la commence à travailler sur les vaccins
et des traitements des médicaments nous
avons sous vide des vies tout au long de
ces mois et cette vitesse grand v frein
qu'avant la fin de l'année nous aurons
des vaccins la réalité c'est que quand
vous regardez le plein de baden on
dirait que c'est exactement ce que nous
avons fait la maison blanche depuis le
début franchement quand je regarde leurs
plans où il est question du dépistage la
protection personnelle le vaccin est
vrai que c'est du plagiat et dubaï
d'annoncer quelque chose n'est-ce pas le
peuple américain ainsi que c'est un
président qui a mis l'amérique et au
premier plein émoi dans mon coeur je
suis vraiment à faire des sacrifices
consentis dans par tous les gens qui ont
pu sauver des vies sa maîtrise est ce
que vous aimeriez absolument tout ce que
le vice président dick l'administration
indique clairement ça n'a pas fonctionné
deux cent dix mille décès dans notre
pays des vies américaines perdu des
familles en deuil
le vice président et le chef de ce
groupe de travail le 28 janvier à quel
point c'était sérieux et grâce à ben
brewer
on a appris qu'ils étaient coup au
courant et quand c'était exposés le vice
président a dit quand on lui a demandé
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez rien dit
il a dit parce que le président voulait
que les gens restent calmes a nommé
soudain c'est important tout ça monsieur
le président monsieur le vice-président
je parle
merci alors je vous demander au peuple
américain
à quel point est ce que vous étiez calme
quand vous étiez en train de chercher du
papier toilette quand les enfants sont
revenus de l'école à quel point ce que
vous étiez calme sans vent ne pouvait
pas voir les parents parce qu'on avait
parlé tué demandons maintenant on
vice-président en vue de répondre tous
les jours je pense aux familles qui ont
perdu un être cher
j'aimerais que vous sachiez que vous
êtes tous et toutes dans mon coeur et
dans nos prières mais quand vous voyez
ce que le peuple américain fait depuis
huit mois et que vous dites que cela n'a
pas fonctionné c'est vraiment ne pas
rendre service aux sacrifices consentis
par les américains la réalité le sud est
c'est terminé
la réalité c'est que le docteur fait il
a bien dit tout ce qu'il a dit au
président le bureau ovale le président
l'a dit au peuple américain
le présenterons je puis vous dire a
énormément de confiance dans le pape
américain a toujours parlé avec la
confiance que nous allions traverser la
preuve ensemble mais quand vous dites
que cela n'a pas fonctionné
le docteur pham chi l'ha dr bugs et nous
experts nous ont vu la deuxième semaine
de mars
si le présent n'avait pas pris cette
décision de fermer tout près la moitié
de l'économie américaine on aurait pu
perdre 2,2 millions de vies américaines
voilà la réalité
avec amazing l'islande comme il fallait
nous pouvions encore perdre plus de 200
mille américains donc une vie perdue
c'est une de trop
mais le peuple américain j'estime mérite
beaucoup de crédit pour tous les
sacrifices consentis au nom de la santé
de leur famille de leur poser et tout le
personnel médical is président de ces
gens dont vous étiez dans un événement
qui était un événement de super
contagion il n'y avait pas distanciation
sociale ni physique il n'y avait pas
vraiment de masques et là on se rend
compte qu'il ya un poids juste foyer de
contagion
comment vous attendez vous à ce que les
américains respectent les normes et les
règles pour éviter la propagation
lorsque vous n'avez pas suivi ses
recommandations et fait preuve depuis
huit mois maintenant que quand les faits
sont à leur portée ils sont prêts à
mettre au premier plan la santé de leurs
proches leurs voisins avec le président
nous avons beaucoup de confiance en le
peuple américain de digérer cette
information aidé à concrétiser au moment
fort de l'épidémie quand nous perdions
un nombre incroyable de mille cinq cents
américains par jour
il nous avons envoyé des ressources en
outre jeudi à new york à nouvelle
orléans à détroit et nous avons dit aux
américains ce qu'il fallait faire ils
ont été d'accord
et quand on le sait dans le vus ces
éclosions dans les états du sud c'est la
même chose mais la réalité c'est que le
président coty travailler le poste à
pourvoir à la cour suprême des etats
unis nous a surpris
hélas la juge amy smith président mais
je peux vous dire que cet événement de
la roseraie ya eu beaucoup de
conjectures
on impose car les mois on était là c'est
un honneur beaucoup de gens ont été
testés pour le virus et c'est un
événement dehors et tulou scentifique
l'eau le conseil
la différence cette fois-ci c'est que le
président trompé moi faisons confiance
au peuple américain
de faire des choix dans le meilleur
intérêt de leur santé joe biden et kaman
à alès il parle le mandat est non
seulement avec le virus mais le
gouvernement va maîtriser merci
président mais de la santé le nouveau
pacte 20 nous voulons lavea liberté
n'ont ni le respecte il respecter les
américains et les américaines voulait
respecter quand vous dites la vérité
voulait respecter quand vous avez le
courage d'être un leader qui parle de
ces choses peut-être difficile mais que
les gens doivent entendre pour se
protéger mais cette administration a
caché de la formation si vous vous aviez
eu des informations comme parents comme
travail art si vous étiez au courant que
vous n'aviez pas assez d'argent et
maintenant vous faites la crue à la
banque alimentaire à cause de l'aisne
est bâti tude d'une administration
incapable de dire la vérité au peuple
américain donc parlons de comment
s'occuper du peuple américain
ils ont sacrifié bien trop à cause de
l'incompétence de cette accusation c'est
trop demander au peuple trop demander au
peuple
s'ils sont pas équipés de l'information
nécessaire pour pouvoir se protéger pour
protéger leurs parents et leurs enfants
s'est montrée intéresse ça va je suis
qu'à ma leur nom afin que la vie
revienne à la normale
docteur pham chi et les experts disent
que les gens qui doivent être vaccinés
or le vaccin
par contre il ya beaucoup d'américains
qui disent qu'il ne ferait pas le vaccin
qui ne prendrait pas de vaccin c'est un
vaccin est approuvée est ce que les
américains devraient prendre le vaccin
si les professionnels de la santé
publique dr faye chez les médecins nous
disent de prendre je serai la première à
prendre le vaccin crûment mais si donald
trump me dit de le prendre je le prends
pas
vice-président et oui je ne gagne des
répercussions suite à cette pandémie
le diagnostic du président a démontré à
quel point le rôle que vous occupez est
important et voici notre deuxième sujet
le rôle du vice président vous allez
marquer l'histoire en janvier que ce
soit vous ou vos 74 ans joe biden aura
plus de 70 ans également
les électeurs sont inquiets sont
inquiets face à ce fait le
vice-président pence avez vous parlé
avec le président de choc pour ce qui
concerne des processus
si jamais il arrivait un problème
présidentielle une incapacité
présidentiel r si j'aimerais peut-être
retenue merci mais j'aimerais quand même
revenir un peu c'est que la réalité
c'est que nous aurons un vaccin
sénatrice et en temps record
c'est du jamais vu en moins d'un an nous
avons cinq entreprises qui sont en
troisième phase des essais cliniques et
maintenant nous produisons des dizaines
de millions de doses le fait que vous
continuez de porter atteinte à la
confiance du public en un vaccin
si le vaccin est émergent cependant le
gouvernement trompe je pense que c'est
vraiment inacceptable sénatrice arrêter
de faire de la partisanerie avec la vie
des gens
la réalité c'est que nous aurons un
vaccin et nous pensons même avant la fin
de l'année et ce vaccin aura la capacité
de sauver d'innombrables vies
américaines et vous continuez de porter
atteinte à la confiance du peuple
américaine dans un vaccin c'est
inacceptable et j'aimerais également
rajouté arrêté c'est que quand vous
parlez des échecs
en fait nous savons le quel est le
visage de l'échec en 2009
c'était la grippe porcine heureusement
ce n'était pas aussi mortel que le
coronavirus mais avant la fin de cette
année là quand d'urbanisme était vice
président des états unis pas 7 million
et demi il avait attrapé ses dires plat
soit 100 millions d'américains l'avait
si la grippe porcine avait été aussi
mortel que le corps d'un virus en 2009
quand le d'aubade elle était vice
président on aurait pu perdre 2 millions
d'américains son propre chef de cabinet
a dit l'année dernière que c'était par
pure chance qu'ils ont je cite fait tout
ce qu'on pouvait faire mal
ils ont comme chaque erreur possible et
nous avons tiré les leçons
il a laissé la réserve nationale vide et
plein vide quand ils sont présents
et moi j'aimerais redire tu arrêter de
porter résidant à la confiance je vais
vous poser la même question
la question est la suivante avez vous
parlé avec baden en ce qui concerne des
procédures ou des balises s'il advenait
que le président soit incapacité et si
vous n'avez pas eu cette conversation
est ce que vous pensez que vous devez
assez loin voyons d'abord le jour où
j'ai eu l'appel de joe biden c'était un
appel zoom en fait et m'a demandé d'être
sur le ticket tu es donc c'était un jour
très mé ment un bon j'ai pensé à ma mère
est venue aux états unis à l'âge de 19
ans l'a couché deux mois quand elle
avait 25 ans à l'hôpital kaiser à
oakland en californie et le fait que je
sois ici aujourd'hui je sais que elle et
elle serait très fier de moi me regarde
joey - ont été élevés de façon très
semblables avec des valeurs qui portent
sur le travail acharné sur la valeur
la dignité associés aux services publics
et l'importance de se battre pour la
dignité de tous et de toutes
il m'a demandé de travailler avec lui
dans ma carrière j'étais la première
procureur à s'imposer ce que j'ai créé
des modèles d'innovation pour les forces
de l'ordre pour la réforme j'étais élue
première femme de couleur et femmes
noires élu procureur général de l'état
de la californie
j'ai géré le deuxième plus grand
département de justice dans les temps
j'ai dû gérer les organismes
internationaux propriétaires les anciens
combattants et maintenant je suis
sénatrice deuxième femme de couleur et
lui je suis sûr le comité d'intelligence
je reçois régulièrement de l'information
confidentielle par rapport aux menaces à
notre nomination j'ai voyagé autour du
monde
j'ai rencontré le soldat dans les zones
de guerre et john m'a demandé de
travailler avec lui parce qu'il sait qu
on partage un objectif donc remonter le
peuple américain et au bout des quatre
ans de donnant 30
on veut unifier notre pays at on appris
auprès à metz vous avez eu ni le
président ni monsieur baden nom des
normes de santé il a été indiqué que des
questions sur la santé n'ont pas été
répondu est-ce que l'information sur la
santé doit être des informations que les
électeurs mais à savoir si j'aimerais
peut-être des réunions du président et
la première dame à quel point nous avons
été touchés
toutes les prières et l'infection
exprimée à l'égard du président
je crois que c'est symbolique des
prières et des préoccupations qui ont
été exprimées par tous les proches des
américains touchés par le virus
mais les soins reçus par le président à
walter reed et les médecins la maison
blanche était exceptionnelle et leur
transparence va continuer le peuple
américain a le droit de savoir ce qui se
passe avec la santé de leur président
mais moi je suis dans la gratitude savez
vous j'étais vraiment ému et
profondément touché var et la madame la
sénatrice et j'aimerais vous remercier
avoué monsieur joe biden également de
vous marque de respect et j'aimerais
vous féliciter comme je lé fais lors de
notre appel sur l'aspect historique de
votre nomination ici comme colistière je
ne m'attendais pas à être ici il ya
quatre ans alors je connais ce que vous
vivez
mais la réalité demeure que nous avons
des élections devant le pape et briquets
l'enjeu n'a jamais merci monsieur le
vice président vincent clerc j'aimerais
que la sénatrice raïs et la chance de
répondre à cette question est ce que les
électeurs devraient pouvoir connaître
plus de renseignements sur la santé des
comme ça et c'est pour ça que joe boyd a
été si transparent et en comparaison le
président n'a pas été aussi transparent
en termes de dossiers de santé et les
impôts
nous savons maintenant grâce aux
journalistes que dans altran papier 750
$ en impôts quand j'ai entendu ça
littéralement j'ai dit vous voulez dire
750 mille dollars non 750 dollars nous
savons que donald trump d'une loi et est
en dette est endetté pour 400 millions
de dollars et juste pour que ça soit
clair quand on dit endettés ça veut dire
que vous devez de l'argent à quelqu'un
ça serait bien de savoir
à qui le commandant en chef le président
des états unis à qui ces personnes-là
doit de l'argent parce que le peuple
américain à bout rond a le droit de
savoir ce qui influence les décisions du
président est-ce qu'il prend des
décisions en votre meilleur intérêt ou
en son propre intérêt alors oui il nous
faut de la transparence et la
transparence doit exister partout
jo a été transparent depuis des années
une des choses qu'on sait au sujet de
joe hill met tout sur la table
il est honnête et les eaux claires dans
la halle 30 par contre couvre tous merci
merci madame la sénatrice monsieur le
vice-président alesi le respecte le fait
que joe biden a passé 47 ans avait pas
laissé que je respecte votre service
public également le peuple américain en
présenc est un homme d'affaires
quelqu'un qui crée des emplois qui a
payé des dizaines de millions $ n'est
pour et taxes sur la masse salariale
la taxe foncière et à cri des dizaines
de milliers de ces emplois américains
il a dit que les reportages n'étaient
pas précis et le président également un
divulgué des documents des piles de
documents de divulgation financière mais
la différence ici c'est que jobs à 2047
en carrière politique comparée à dans
notre top qui a mené toute cette
expérience il ya quatre ans je me suis
présidence former l'économie en
réduisant les impôts
on al'exemple un règlement en libéral
énergie en libéral comme et arrière
désaxé toute la différence
de gens là sujet l'économie c'est un
aspect de la vie américaine qui a été
affectés par la pandémie
il ya une crise de l'emploi nous avons
appris que le chômage avait baissé
et ça c'était avant qu'il y ait toutes
les mises à pied dans plusieurs secteurs
comme le secteur aérien
11 millions d'emplois n'ont pas été
remplacés ceux qui sont affectés le plus
ce sont les femmes les noirs et les
latinos entre autres la campagne buy dan
harris à proposer des initiatives vous
impose auriez plus de taxes et d'impôts
sur les plus riches de la société
est ce que le fait d'augmenter les taxes
franc sorte que la relance seraient à
risque
vous avez deux minutes par rapport à
l'économie
et on ne peut pas il ne peut pas y avoir
une grosse une plus grosse différence
entre dans la halle trump et jordan
lebel croit qu'on mesure la force et la
santé de l'économie basée sur la force
du travailleur et de la famille
américaine en contrepartie en un dollar
donald trump qui mesure la force de
l'économie basée sur à quel point les
gens sont riches
c'est pour ça qu'il a adopté une loi des
impôts al'avantage des plus riches et
des plus grandes entreprises menant un
déficit de 2 mille milliards de dollars
payables par le peuple américain au
premier jour
dubai de cette loi il va la retirer elma
aisés d'investir l'argent dans le peuple
libyen qui a donc il va investir dans
l'infrastructure quelque chose que dans
altran pas dit qu'il allait faire ya
jamais eu de résultats
medjo bad va investir dans les routes
les ponts les énergies propres les
énergies renouvelables jo
investir cet argent là dans tout ce
qu'il faut faire au niveau de
l'innovation et fut un temps où notre
pays croyait dans la science et
investissez dans la recherche et le
développement pour qu'on soit -leader
d'innovation autour du monde joe biden
va utiliser cet argent là pour investir
dans l'éducation donc par exemple pour
les gens qui veulent aller à
l'université ou un au collège
communautaire de deux ans ça sera
gratuit si vous voulez aller à une
université publique ça sera gratuit et
en règle générale si vous avez une dette
étudiante ça sera diminuée de 10 mille
dollars
c'est comme ça que jobs hayden ne pense
à l'économie c'est une question
d'investir dans notre peuple plutôt que
d'adopter une loi sur les impôts qui
avait l' avantage pour les entreprises
américaines qui pouvaient quitter le
pays
mr face entre les airs monsieur le vice
président notre administration prévoit
une relance forte
cependant les rapports démontrent que ce
n'est pas le cas pour l'instant est ce
que les américains doivent s'attendre à
une relance qui prendra des mois sinon
des années comment le présent nous avons
pris le pouvoir
on l'avait connu la reprise économique
la plus longue depuis la grande
dépression
il a essayé d'imposer les gens arrêtent
de dépenser à gauche à droite quand il
était vice présent mais se trompe
coupez les impôts malgré ce que la
sénatrice a dit la famille moyenne de 4
personnes à 2000 $ de plus grâce à ça et
avec les salaires remonter surtout pour
les américains d'atlanta ouvrière les
revenus moyens ont augmenté dès 4000 $
après les réductions d'impôt ne me
trompe mais vous venez d'entendre madame
harris le dire dès le premier jour dubaï
va faire augmenter vos impôts si
remarquable quand vous ai pensé tout de
suite après une époque où on traverse
une pandémie
on l'a 22 millions d'emplois perdus on a
déjà rajouté 11,6 millions d'emplois
car nous avons un président qui a
vraiment libérés l'énergie américaine
réduit les impôts et un réussi à tenir 4
milliards de dollars avec des paiements
directs les familles 50 millions
d'emplois sauvés par le programme
on a tout fait pour aider le peuple
américain et le travailleur américain
joe biden comme valls veut la faire
augmenter les impôts
ils veulent vraiment écouté ce docte de
l'économie verte
vous avez été une déco parraine aux
parraineurs au sénat ils veulent et
éliminer les carburants fossiles est
aussi éliminé la fracturation
cela éliminerait des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois n'en midwest à djerba
et une vers tournai vraiment à la
relation dans marca chine la moitié du
déficit commercial est avec la chine et
djerba et elle veut enlever tous les
tarifs imposée par monsieur trempe pour
que se battre pour l'emploi en amérique
et on dit que la plaie mocratie sur le
bulletin de vote
sachez le c'est l'économie c'est le
retour américain qui est sur le bulletin
de vote avec les 90 résidents avec le
présenterons mairie novateur ça va être
l année de retour économique conforme à
vue je pense que on a déjà vu assez de
ça dans le débat de la semaine dernière
mais ce débat est censé être axée sur la
vérité de baleine a été très claire les
gens qui se dégage du jus de réduction
d'impôt sur ce toujours vice-président
je parle je parle mais il faut dire la
vérité non ce joe budden la 10 des voix
il va abroger les réductions d'impôt ne
se trompent s'adonner à la même famille
moyenne américaine 2000 $ en un
allègement fiscal à chaque année
c'est absolument pas vrai mais il va
juste abrogé une partie de ce projet
tout ça vous dérange pas je préfère
terminer on pourra avoir une
conversation sénatrice joe biden ne va
pas augmenter les impôts sur les gens
qui ne gagnent moins que 400 mille
dollars par année
il va pas finir et de 9,1 à la
fracturation il a été très clair joe
biden est celui qui pendant la grande
récession était responsable de la loi
sur la reprise économique qui a fait
revenir les états unis et maintenant
l'administration 30 pence veut prendre
cette reconnaissance alors qu'ils ont
tout simplement suivi le succès de joe
biden pour l'économie au début de ce
mandat évidemment l'économie est un
désastre total maintenant mais c'est
john c'est joe biden qui a fait ça
en contrepartie on à donald trump qui a
contrôlé récession pire que la grande
dépression
en contrepartie on à joe biden
responsable avec barack obama pour la
loi sur les soins à prix abordable pour
protéger les américains avec des
conditions préexistantes et ça sauve et
les familles qui auraient dû déclarer
faillite à cause des frais médicaux dans
l'ain trempe et devront trimer un site
réservé pour tenter de se débarrasser de
la loi sur les soins à prix abordable ce
qui veut dire que si vous avez une
condition préexistante vous allez ne pas
avoir une couverture sans prétention et
j'aimerais terminer s'il vous plaît si
vous avez une condition préexistante et
les maladies cardiaques le diabète le
cancer du sein
ils viennent nous chercher si vous aimez
quelqu'un avec une condition président
ils viennent vous chercher oui madame
cézanne à peine moins que 26 ans et vous
êtes sur la couverture ne vaut pas rêver
une recherche d'un hamac cimenterie nous
allons donner la balle
que nous pourrons parler de la santé
parce qu'elle l'obamacare 7ème
catastrophe les américains s'en rappelle
très bien le présente en paix - avons un
plan pour améliorer les soins de santé
et afin de protéger les haies et
conditions préexistantes pour chaque
américain
écoutez vous avez droit votre opinion
mais pas vos propres faits vous même
vous avez dit à de nombreuses reprises
quand vous vous présenter à la
présidence que vous alliez bannir la
fracturation pour le pétrole les aubades
et me regarde les partisans a dit moi je
vous le garantis je garantis que nous
allons mettre une feuille aux carburants
fossiles
hélas le pacte vers votre journal
cette idée est dit que ce n'était pas
très différent du pack vert de régimes
plus d'impôts plus de règlements
l'abolition de la fracturation pas de
kabran facile écrasé l'énergie
américaine et la soumission économique à
la chaîne
ça c'est un déclin économique
appréhender nous avec me trompe
nous aurons une reprise en forme de v
qui est en marche maintenant et avec
quatre années de plus de monsieur john
baird et reprise est garanti sur le
vice-président et d'ailleurs nous allons
passer à l'autre sujet du changement
climatique
j'aimerais vous poser la première
question monsieur le vice présidence
cette année il y a eu plusieurs
incidents des ouragans
l'ouragan delta d'ailleurs qu'il a en ce
moment il ya eu des feux de forêt dans
l'ouest
est ce que vous pensez tel qu'il a été
conclu par les scientifiques que le
changement climatique causé par l'homme
a rendu les incidents climatiques plus
dangereux et plus grave
vous avez deux minutes pour l'heure
c'est super avant tout je suis très fier
de notre feuille de route
l'environnement et la conservation selon
tous les meilleurs scientifiques notre
ère et nos territoires et plus propre de
l'histoire et l'eau est la plus propre
du monde et il n'y a pas longtemps la
présence signé un décret
visant le plus grand investissement dans
la conservation à 100 ans
donc le présent troupes s'est engagée la
conservation l environnement maintenant
pour le changement climatique
c'est vrai on assiste à des changements
climatiques mais la question est celle
ci qu'elle est à cause et que pouvons
nous faire
le présentant pas dit clairement que
nous allons continuer d'écouter les
scientifiques des robes haydn par contre
et kamala harris voudrait nous faire
retourner aux accords de paris et le
pacte vert qui écraserait le secteur
énergétique et pourrait augmenter le
coût de l'énergie pour les américaines
et pourrait donc écrasé l'emploi le
présente un peu moins croyants par
exemple que le progrès que nous avons
enregistrées jusqu'ici dans un
environnement plus propre et bien c'est
justement grâce au fait que nous avons
un marché libre ce qui est remarquable
c'est que les états unis ont réduit les
émissions de gaz carbonique davantage
que les pays qui sont encore dans les
accords de paris mais cela grâce à
l'innovation et nous l'avons réussi
grâce au gaz naturel et la fracturation
qui madame la sénatrice et les
américains peuvent regarder de ce que
joe biden le biais comme vous c'est à
dire contrairement à la vérité mais
comme une fois avez-vous promis d'abolir
les carburants fossiles et d' interdire
la fracturation donc en ayant
l'innovation américaine nous sommes
entrés nous diriger vers un
environnement plus propre et quant aux
feux de forêt je présente rampe et moi
pensons que la gestion forestière doit
être au coeur du débat
et monsieur nous sommes de votre état
est d'accord qu'il faut mieux gérer nos
forêts et quant aux règles nationales de
la météo nous dit que la guerre qui
avait mis à 100 ans mais alarmiste
servent pour vraiment faire
a volé le nouveau pacte vert mais nous
allons mettre l'emploi au premier plein
voilà tout c'est notre et crs vous avez
été co sponsor du renew diot la semaine
passée il a été établi que le green new
deal n'est pas soutenu par monsieur
byden cependant dans votre site web
le green new deal est un cadre important
donc quelle est votre approche par
rapport à d'abord je me répète et le
peuple américain c'est que joe biden ne
va pas interdire la fracturation ça
c'est un fait ça c'est un fait je me
répète joe biden a été très clair qu'ils
pensent à faire croître le nombre
d'emplois donc c'est pour ça qu'ils ne
va pas augmenter les impôts pour les
gens qui gagnent moins que 400 milliards
par année
le plan économique moody's donc un
cabinet la réputation a dit qu'on l'a
écrit 7 million de postes de plus que
donald trump
une partie de ces postes créés par joe
biden vont porter sur les énergies
propres et renouvelables
parce que vous savez que joe comprend
que la côte ouest de notre pays
drulhe y compris mon état de la
californie joe voir ce qui se passe dans
les états du golfe détruits par les
tempêtes les fermiers en ohio a qui ont
perdu leurs récoltes à cause des
inondations
je crois dans la science je vais vous
dire quelque chose suzanne quand j'ai
commencé comme sénatrice j'étais sur le
comité responsable de l'environnement
vous savez que cette administration a
pris le mot science du site web l'a
enlevée et ensuite à retirer le mot
changement climatique du site web
il y à un pétrin avec cette
administration cette administration ne
crois pas dans la science et le plan de
jo et de diers on va gérer ça mais on va
également créer des emplois donald trump
lorsqu'on demande qu'est ce qui se passe
avec les feux un contre et un contrôle
et en californie et dilation et on dit
la science tremblay dit
la science ne sais pas alors qui est
prêt à mener notre paix lui sur les
quatre prochaines années
en ce qui concerne une menace
existentielle vous être une drôle dit on
va créer des millions d'emplois
on va travailler sur l'énergie on va
avoir zéro émission d'ici 20 50 carbone
neutre d'ici 20 35 jo un plan trompe
recul nous allons également prendre
l'accord avec fierté la sénatrice a
redit qu'il s'agit là d'une menace
existentielle ce que vous pensez que le
changement climatique est une menace
existentielle qui me change nous voyons
ce qui se passe nous le constatons mais
de nouveau la sénatrice russe ni le fait
qu'ils vont faire augmenter les impôts
dubai des nazis deux fois lors du débat
de la semaine dernière et dès le premier
jour de son gouvernement il allait
abroger les réductions d'impôts de cette
chambre
ça c'est 2000 $ d'allègement fiscal pour
la famille moyenne de 4 personnes en
amérique pour ce que la fracturation
moi je recommande que les gens regardent
la feuille de route vous même vous avez
dit ahmet reprise que vous alliez
abandonné la fracturation
vous êtes la première à parrainer le new
deal vert et merci souviens de l'avoir
dit c'est sur leur site web de campagne
comme il ya cette maladie c'est vraiment
le même plein et vous avez parrainer
cela avec alexandra cortese et vous avez
dit que nous aller nous re soumettre aux
accords de paris mais le peuple
américain a toujours chéri notre
environnement nous allons continuer de
le chérir nous avons beaucoup progressé
nous avons réduit les gaz carboniques
grâce à l'innovation américaine et au
développement du gaz naturel et la
fracturation
nous n'avons pas besoin de new deal
2 2 milliards de dollars 2 billions de
dollars qui va écraser les familles les
commerces et les entreprises président
d'élection de rénover de façon éco
énergétiques quatre millions d'immeubles
et de résidence mais c'est insensé
penser à l'emploi en premier et
l'environnement suivre mais sur la
question des emplois en parlant de ça le
vice président tout à l'heure à 10 enfin
quelque chose qui selon lui est une
réussite
c'est la guerre commerciale avec la
chine vous avez perdu cette guerre
commerciale vous l'avez perdu qu'est ce
qui s'est passé à cause d'une guerre
commerciale soit disant avec la chine on
a perdu 300000 emplois de fabrication
les agriculteurs sont en faillite à
cause de ça nous sommes dans une
récession de fabrication à cause de ça à
cause de ça et lorsqu'on rien de cette
administration
on évalue que d'ici la fin du mandat de
cette administration
il aurait perdu plus d'emplois que
n'importe quelle question qui et
n'importe quel autre administration et
le peuple america sais de quoi je parle
vous savez je pense aux jeunes de 20 ans
on a un enfant de 20 kg année il quitte
l'école secondaire l'université et vous
vous posez la question est-ce que je
vais avoir un emploi
des gens qui vont qui se pose la
question comment payer mon loyer
la moitié presque la moitié des
américains qui payent un loyer
s'inquiètent de leur loyer pour la fin
du mois c'est ça l'économie américaine
présentement à cause de la catastrophe
et l'échec de leadership de cette
administration
merci sénatrice avait monsieur le
vice-président j'avoue donné 15 secondes
pour alors j'aimerais bien répondre en
effet on a perdu la guerre commerciale
urban n'était pas présent lui il est un
danseur à claquettes de la chine
communiste depuis le début de sa
carrière il avait le droit à votre
opinion mais pas vous fait lui bayonne
comme vice président a perdu deux cent
mille emplois ne m'avait facturier et le
présent obama dit qu'ils n'allaient
jamais revenir on a besoin d'une
baguette magique pour les voir dans look
trois premières années après tout mis
sur le vice-président décision notre
mouvement a vu cinq cent mille emplois
manufacturiers être crier c'est
exactement le genre de croissance que
nous allons voir à mesure que nous
traversons seulement 10 président avec
un new deal vert et tous vos accords de
paris cela va tuer l'emploi tout comme
cela tu es l'emploi la dcrg besoin de
répondre très rapidement avec 1 0 merci
jean paredes est responsable de sauver
l'industrie automobile des états unis et
vous avez voté contre cela alors disons
les choses comme elles sont j'aimerais
maintenant parler de la chine
we have no - c'est notre prochain sujet
de notre relation avec la chine est très
compliqué et plein de conséquences la
chine est un énorme marché pour les
biens agricoles également un moyen de
communication avec d'autres pays
le président antoine a mis la faute sur
la chine pour le coronavirus comment
vous décrivez notre relation avec la
chine ce sont des amis nous c'est sous
des adversaires vous avez deux minutes
pour répondre avant cela j'aimerais
peut-être aborder le sujet précédent
chacun sait que l'alena côté des
milliers de ces emplois dans le secteur
manufacturier on a vu l'emploi dans
l'automobile quitté vers le mexique
on a voulu renégocier l'alena et
maintenant la cellule et la nouvelle loi
du continent le peuple américain mérite
de savoir que madame russe
est un des seuls dix membres sénat de
voter contre l'asim
c'était une grande victoire pour le
secteur de l'automobile une grande
victoire pour les fermiers surtout dans
le secteur des ti dans le midwest nom et
vous dit que ce n'était pas assez sur le
côté écologique que vous mettez vos
priorités radicale de la gauche verte à
l'avant plein plus important que le
travailleur américain
vous méritez de le savoir monsieur
madame tout le monde en fait c'était la
personne la plus à gauche du sénat 2019
plus à gauche comme ce sens deux plus à
gauche que tous les sénateurs du sénat
alors pour la chine maintenant ce sont
avant tout
tu es responsable du coronavirus c'est
là que le blâme doit être claire et ne
se tromp l'adil clairement lâché ne m'a
pas été honnêtes selon l' oms
ils n'ont pas permis à notre personnel
d'un trait en chine pour avoir les
informations ce virus jusqu'à la mi
février
heureusement le président trompe en
transigeant avec la chine dès le début a
tenu tête aux chinois qui ont profité
depuis des décennies de notre peuple et
cela avec d'urbandale dans les estrades
en train d'être un champion de la chine
communiste et nous on a suspendu tout
déplacement le chinois et le peuple
américain mérite de savoir dubaï
d'honnêteté qui contraint décision de
fermer les frontières ou chinoise il a
dit que c'était hystérique que cet
exercice a tenu tête à la chine et nous
allons continuer de nous gêner efforts
nous voulons améliorer la relation mais
nous voulons que la chine soit
responsable de ce qu'ils ont fait au
peuple américain
avec ce livre je vais vous poser la même
question comment vous décrivez notre
relation fondamentale avec la chine
nous sommes concurrents adversaire
ennemis vous avez deux minutes selon
l'administration trompe et leurs points
de vue et leurs approches à la chine a
fait perdre des vies des emplois et la
réputation aux états unis il ya une
drôle up ces trolls d'obsession que dans
la trempe de se débarrasser de toute
réussite de barack obama et de son
administration par exemple au sein de la
maison blanche
ils ont créé un bureau responsable de
gérer les pandémies
mais l'administration s'en est
débarrassé administration 30 il y avait
une équipe d'experts de maladie que le
président obama a envoyé
en chine pour surveiller ce qui s'est
produit finalement mais cette
administration la retirer deux cent dix
mille américaines ont perdu la vie
regardons la situation des emplois nous
avons parlé des accords commerciaux la
guerre commerciale qui voulait dire avec
la chine
le résultat était la perte de trois
cents mille emplois en fabrication et le
consommateur américain à payer des
milliers de dollars de plus pour des
biens à cause de cette guerre des choix
et parlons de réputation pew
lagence de recherche a fait une analyse
qui montre que les leaders de tous nos
pays anciennement alliés ont décidé que
jj ping est bien plus respecté le chef
du parti communiste que donald trump
le président des états unis le
commandant en chef des états unis c'est
ça la réalité d'aujourd'hui à cause d'un
échec
de leadership par cet artiste nous avons
pu observer des changements dans le rôle
qu'occupe les états unis sur la scène
internationale nous avons vu qu'il y
avait des tensions avec la chine
nous avons vu des tensions avec nos
alliés traditionnels à l'otan par
exemple comment définissez vous le
leadership américain en 2020 vous savez
j'adore parler avec jaws sur tous ces
sujets je pense qu'il l'a bien dit il
dit la politique étrangère peut-être que
vous avez l'impression que c'est
compliqué mais c'est des relations
donc on le sait pour ses excès des
relations faut tenir sa parole auprès de
ses amis pour montrer la fidélité
si les gens nous appuient faut les
appuyer il faut connaître nos
adversaires et les sur 10 mais ce qu'on
a vu avec donald trump
c'est que il est allé à l'encontre de
nos amis et là il est allé chercher des
dictateurs au tour du monde prenons la
rue si par exemple je suis sur le comité
de l'intelligence du sénat américain
la communauté de l'intelligence nous a
dit que la russie s'est ingéré dans les
élections en 2016
christopher est le directeur de l'afd a
dit la même chose mais donald trump le
commandant en chef des états unis
préfèrent de croire la dmr poutine
plutôt que la communauté de
l'intelligence américain nos amis à
l'otan il les a quittés et l'entente
l'accord nucléaire de l'iran il est il a
quitté nous mettons dans une situation
beaucoup plus 20 / on était dans cette
entente avec des alliés
et comme donald trump une approche et
unilatérale il avec son approche de
s'isoler
il nous a mis en danger donc c'est une
question de relation ce qui a toujours
été une force de notre nation c'était
notre parole
avec notre armée nos forces armées
mais donald trump ne comprend pas ici
parce que c'est à travers la sénatrice
c'est à vous monsieur le vice président
si le président entend certainement
respecté sa parole quand il a déménagé
l'ambassade de tel aviv à jérusalem dur
baden avait promis l'a jamais fait nous
sommes très forts au côté nous aller
mais nous avons aussi exigeant
l'otan ne contribuait pas assez et
maintenant grâce aux lilas jeune homme
se trompe il contribue beaucoup plus ont
renforcé nos alliances dans la zee basse
faits qui nous avons été forts contre
ceux qui nous voudraient du tort vous
savez quand le présentons pas pris le
pouvoir
dash avait là mais miss sur un
territoire que la grandeur de la
pennsylvanie est là mais se trompe a
libéré nous force militaire me détruit
leur khalifa
sans aucune victime américaine al
bagdadi était responsable de la mort de
milliers d'êtres humains mais nous aux
coeurs sont avec les parents de camille
et ses parents sont avec nous alors
excédé aujourd'hui deux des tueurs de
neige responsable de la mort de kehl ont
été traduits en justice aux états unis
djallit john a été tué sur le champ de
combat la réalité demeure que quand je
baille un des vice présidents
on avait l'occasion de sauver la vie de
calmer leur ça me brise le coeur
mais les militaires sont arrivés dans le
bureau ovale avec un plan et qu'il
savait où elle était malade il avait
depuis 18 mois il avait abusé de cette
pauvre fille président a évité pendant
un mois
et quand les militaires sont contre et
c'est clair qu'elles avaient été
déménagés deux jours auparavant et sa
famille nous dit avec le coeur brisé
les lames à l'oeil si le président de
chambre avait été président à l'époque
mais nous avons détruit le califat de
dèche et si vous pensez de retourner
dans cet accord requiert une somme a
offert 1,8 milliard de la merci monsieur
état qui parrainent le terrorisme ou les
sorties de cela et comme ce sont les
manies se rendent à bagdad américaine le
présente dans le top l'a éliminée
l'amérique est plus en sécurité nous ali
sont en plus en sécurité et le peuple
américains savent que le prénom mais
n'hésitera jamais puisse répondre
par contre s'il vous plaît mais j'aime
avoir d'autres sujets d'abord à la
famille muller je suis au courant de la
situation de votre fille et je suis très
très très désolé très désolé ce qu'elle
a vécu et est
bible et ça n'aurait jamais dû se
produire et je sais que jo ce sans
pareil et je sais que le président obama
se sondent pareil aussi
vous avez mentionné sur la money
commençons par ça après les tirs sur
salamani il y avait contre eux tirent
sur nos troupes en irak
[Musique]
ils ont souffert des traumatismes au
cerveau et dans le train pas dit que
c'était des maux de tête
c'est un patin les armes
les forces armées sont toujours on dit
toujours que c'est des gens qui
s'ouvrait et et ses 12 ans dans notre en
pétales et au cimetière avec tenait près
des cercueils il a dit ça fait quoi pour
eux parce que il ne pense qu'à lui ce
qu'il a dit par exemple au sujet de john
mccain un grand héros amérique
prenons ce qu'il a dit à son sujet
donald trump a dit on ne devrait pas
l'appeler héros parce qu'il était
prisonnier de guerre
et ça c'est très très important quand
vous voulez parler de qui est le
commandant en chef
présentement et ce qui les préoccupe et
ce qu'il écrit quelques pas on savait
que la russie avait mis de l'argent sur
les têtes des soldats vous savez ce que
c'est cet argent c'est appris sur notre
tête et si vous décédez ils vont payer
et donald trump avait parlé au moins six
fois à vladimir poutine et il a jamais
soulevé le sujet joe baden n'aurait
jamais fait ça
joe biden aurait tenus responsables la
russie si jamais il y avait une menace
auprès de notre sécurité auprès de nos
troupes qui sacrifient leur vie pour
notre animatrice
c'est très important mais il faut que
nous parlions d'autres enjeux importants
il faut que je réponde vraiment vous
avez 15 secondes écoutez ce territoire
plus que 15 secondes
je suis désolé monsieur le vice
président vous avez eu plus de temps
qu'elle
il est l homme lit contre le président
change quand il est question désormais
les femmes sous les drapeaux
c'est absurde
mon fils est allé me l'accordé mari me
mon beau fils et dans la marine
je puis vous assurer tout un chacun que
nous militaires et bien notre président
ne fait pas que les respecter mais il ya
de la révérence pour eux et merci
monsieur ridicule soudaine le peuple
américain s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît je n'ai pas compris des règles aux
deux campagnes se sont entendus et ont
approuvé les règles je suis là pour
faire respecter les règles nous devons
passer d'un sujet à l'autre
vous devez obtenir ces mêmes périodes
donc j'aimerais que nous passions au
prochain sujet il s'agit de la cour
suprême
lundi il y aura des séances sur la
nomination de rémi cornubert êtes vous
allez être un membre du comité monsieur
le vice président il est fort probable
qu'elle soit nommée ceci ferait en sorte
que des lois contre l'avortement soit
mise de l'avant
l'accès serait donc difficile madame la
sénatrice et si robbie wade est abrogé
ou plutôt non monsieur le vice président
que feriez vous en votre éducation mais
je vais utiliser un peu de mon temps
pour la question intérieure si je vous
le permettez le peuple américain mérite
de savoir que qasem soleimani le général
iranien responsable de la mort de
centaines de vies américaines militaire
et quand l'occasion s'est présentée
et ils se rendent à bagdad pour tuer
d'autres présidents le présente comme
n'a pas hésité une seconde et qasem
soleimani et partie et vous méritez de
savoir que joe biden et kamla russes ont
critiqué cette décision d'éliminer
qassem suleimani c'est vrai mais il
n'explique abl mais quant à joe budden
son peut l'expliquer car l'histoire ne
montre qu'il était contre la tacc contre
le repaire d'oussama ben laden
il est très important que nous ayons un
commandant en chef qui n'hésiteraient
pas d'agir pour protéger nos militaires
et nos vies et voilà ce qu'est dans
notre choix maintenant pour ce qui est
de la cour suprême
je peux vous dire que nous sommes
vraiment enthousiasmés par l'occasion de
voir la nomination des micros ni
barrette
c'est une femme brillante une juriste
hors pair elle a une vie d'expérience
elle a une grande famille et cela en
plein coeur de la capitale et de la vie
la nation et contrairement au traitement
réservé pour la juge cavaniol nous
espérons qu'elle va voir une audience
juste et équitable et nous espérons ne
pas voir des attaques qu'ont sa foi
chrétienne qu'on a vus auparavant le
président démocrate du comité judiciaire
quand la juge martha été confirmée par
la cour d'appel a préoccupé a exprimé
des préoccupations que le dogme de sa
foi était trop sonore avec double
élément à 10 la sénatrice je sais qu'un
de nos mii de nos candidats vous l'avait
attaquée parce qu'ils faisaient partie
des chevaliers de colomb parce que les
chevaliers de colomb de colons étaient
prouvés merci monsieur le vison les
autres soit pour la nomination de la
juge et méconnu matches j'espère jouira
dans le respect qui lui est dû
et quelle sera la prochaine juge à la
cour suprême des etats unis
vous êtes civ
procureur général de la californie tu es
donc vous posez la même question si
l'eau contre wade est renversé que
voulez vous qu'il se passe dans votre
état d'origine
par rapport à l'accès à l'avortement
merci ce n'est d'abord dubaï donnez moi
nous sommes des gens de foi et c'est
insultant de suggérer que en cracherait
sur la foi de n'importe qui et joe six
élus serait seulement le deuxième
catholique pratiquant comme président
des états unis par rapport à la question
de cette candidate
joe et moi sont très claires
comme la majorité du peuple américain on
est à 27 jours de décider le prochain
président des états unis et auparavant
quand on a parlé de ce sujet bon parler
d'une année électorale ou un moment
électoral nous sommes présentement en
période électorale
plus de 4 millions de personnes ont voté
les gens sont en train de voter à
l'instant
donc j'en étais très clair comme le
peuple américain était très clair
laissez le peuple américain
remplir le siège et ensuite on remplira
le siège au niveau de la cour suprême
la liste des enjeux sur sérieux et à la
question de choix je vais toujours lutté
pour qu'une femme puisse prendre une
décision par rapport à son propre corps
c'est pas la décision de mes copains ou
donald trump et regardons encore c'est
une question de la loi sur les soins aux
prix abordables littéralement en pleine
pandémie ou 210 mille personnes sont
décédées et sept mille personnes ont une
condition préexistante parce que vous
avez été atteints du virus
donald trump et devant le tribunal
aujourd'hui pour se débarrasser de la
loi sur les soins à prix abordable il
n'empêche ça veut dire qu'il n'y aura
plus de pratique sursis gagne n'y aura
plus de protection pour les gens qui ont
des conditions préexistantes ça veut
dire
plus de 20 millions de personnes vont
perdre la assurance si vous perdez si
vous avez moins de 26 ans vous ne pouvez
pas être sûr les assurances de vos
parents le contraste pas de plus clair
il essaie de se débarrasser de la loi
sur les soins à prix abordable joe biden
jean où il a un chalet mais le choix on
va réduire les primes en vain réduire
l'éligibilité la dation ce manager
célébrer leadership vous avez mentionné
quelque chose un peu plus trop où vous
avez dit que le président s'engager à
protéger les gens qui ont une maladie
préexistante
vous avez également dit que le f word
poker acte serait peut-être un projet
donc le président a dit qu'il allait
protéger les personnes qui ont une
cendre au pré existants mais il n'a pas
dit comment il allait le faire
concrètement comment est-ce que votre
administration protégerait les
américains qui ont une condition
préexistante
merci souci est ce que j'aimerais dire
pour votre première question je suis
très fier d'être vice président aux
côtés d'un président qui respecte le
caractère sacro saint de la vie je suis
pro vie et je ne vais pas présenté
d'excusés et satin autre exemple où il
ya un contraste vraiment frappé dur
badini camara russes veulent le
financement public avortement
jusqu'au moment de la naissance un fin
de troisième trimestre ils veulent avoir
du financement
la planification des familles moi je ne
voudrais jamais présumer comment aimer
cours les barrettes va décider mais nous
allons continuer battre pour le droit de
la vie du foetus et quand vous parlez de
la cour suprême le peuple américain
mérite réponse c'est triste
est-ce que vous d'urbanisme à les
remplir le
la cour suprême ait eu vingt neuf postes
à pourvoir pendant des années lectorale
de george washington jusqu'à barack
obama des présidents ont été nommé des
juges au dynamisme et votre parti a
prôné le fait d'ajouter des sièges qui
avait 9 sièges pendant 150 ans si vous
n'avez pas votre propre choix
donc si vous n'arrivez pas à respecter
les règles allaient changer les règles
voulues réfusé de répondre d'urban un
refus de répondre de papa mais rien
voudrais savoir si la juge amy qu'on les
bars étaient confirmés comme juge à la
cour suprême
est ce que vous y jo c'est vous jamais
vous gagner cette élection
allez-vous en 1861 personnes à 13 me sur
le vice président jean me plait merci
d'accord en 1864 un des héros politique
certainement du président et de vous
monsieur et benjamines qui devait se
faire élire sept jours avant les
élections un siège s'est libéré au
niveau de la cour suprême
le parti de l'in qu'elle était occupée
non seulement de la maison blanche mais
de la cour suprême mais une aide a dit
non c'est pas la bonne chose à faire le
peuple américain mérite de prendre
édition par rapport à qui sera le
prochain président des états unis et
c'est cette personne qui va choisir la
personne qui siègera pour une vie à la
cour suprême donc jo et moi nous sommes
très clairs le peuple américain vote
aujourd'hui et ça devrait être leur
décision à savoir qui siègera à la cour
suprême des états-unis agir merci
sénatrice
mais les gens qui votent veulent savoir
c'est vous et d'urbanisme à les élargir
le nombre de juges
si vous ne réussissez par l'homme le
roman et mikko nouvelle
j'essaie réponse mais la réponse c'est
que oui ils vont augmenter le nombre de
juges à la cour suprême
merci le gagner si l'on stresse dernier
des gens partout au pays c'est vous
vraiment vous voulez respecter la
séparation des pouvoirs
rejetée monsieur bail d'un examen
jusqu'à ce que nous allons respecter la
diffusion d'un pouvoir ajouter la cour
suprême à luzy par les uns oui c'est ce
que je fais l'administration 30
parce que je siège au comité du sénat et
j'ai été témoin de ces nominations à la
cour suprême à vis des gens qui sont
purement idéologique des gens revue par
des agences légal qui ont trouvé qu'ils
étaient incompétents sous la norme
et savez-vous que des 50 personnes nommé
à la cour d'appel par le
président ya pas une seule personne
noire c'est ce qu'ils font voulez-vous
parler de remplir les sièges mais son
mal à en parler maintenant parlons de la
justice raciale il n'a jamais répondu à
la question
soyez clair dubaï annoncée la sénatrice
a refusé de répondre je voulais que le
procès verbal le note en mars
brianna telle une technicienne de la
salle d'urgence a été tué après que des
policiers soient entrées dans son
appartement police a indiqué que les
agents se sont identifiés cependant un
ami de brent est le a indiqué qu'il ne
se sont pas présentés une sorte de fer
les policiers ont indiqué qu'ils ont agi
ainsi pour se défendre
madame la sénatrice dans le cas de ben
laden
est ce que la justice un jeune groupe à
j'ai parlé à la mère de rihanna et à sa
famille sa famille nécessite la justice
est une très belle femme
son objectif avi c'était d'être
infirmière elle voulait être
ambulancière pour savoir ce qui se
passait dans la rue pour qu'elle puisse
devenir infirmière pour sauver des vies
et on a pris sa vie de façon violente
sans justification et même
or donc ça me fait revenir aux huit
minutes 46 secondes
que le peuple américain a vu pendant
lesquelles un homme américains étaient
torturés et venant assassiné sous le
genou d'un membre des forces de l'ordre
lorsqu'il était non armés et les gens
partout dans notre pays de toutes races
de tout âge de tout genre des inconnus
de tous ont marché côte à côte
maintenant la main et ont lutté pour
qu'on puisse avoir la justice égale sous
la loi
j'ai fait partie de ces manifestations
visibles
je crois fortement que d'abord on ne va
jamais vouloir la violence mais il faut
toujours lutter en faveur des valeurs
qu'on a dans le coeur y compris un idéal
pour tous les pays c'est pour ça que joe
biden et moi nous avons dit sur ce sujet
je suis ancien procureur je sais de quoi
je parle
on a besoin de réformes on a besoin de
réformer les forces de l'ordre et le
système digestif c'est pour ça que nous
allons automatiquement interdire
certains certaines manoeuvres a fait par
les forces de l'ordre
floyd aurait été vivant aujourd'hui si
on avait fait ça avant on a besoin de
réformer on doit se débarrasser des
prisons privées
mais l'argent nécessaire envers les
criminels sénatrice cannabis et nous
allons les plus chelsea man le dos de
ceux qui ont été mal accusé madame à cet
âge ils ont été coulés gel présente voie
à ce niveau je vais vous poser la même
question monsieur le vice président dans
le cas de bruno telle heure est ce que
la justice a été rendue
vous avez deux minutes j'avais bien
notre coeur est brisé devant la perte de
toute vie innocente en amérique
je fais confiance à notre système de
justice
le grand jury a refusé d'inculper les
policiers et commence à une procureure
vous présumez qu'un grand jury qui a
toutes les preuves devant eux font
partie du système pénal mais vous avez
droit à votre opinion madame la
sénatrice m pour georges floyd il n'y a
aucune excuse pour ce qu'il a vécu la
justice sera rendue
mais il ya également aucune excuse pour
les émeutes et les pillages qui ont
suivi écouté cet étonnant il y a
quelqu'un parmi nous assure excédé il ya
deux semaines j'étais de 20 son salon de
coiffure brûlés par des émeutes y des
pilleurs et flora l'ancien propriétaire
de son salon et c'est de rebâtir ce
n'est pas chose facile
cette présomption est trop fréquentes
chez djoubaye dénis cannabis à savoir
que nous avons du reste si c'est mickey
comme dubaï de nazis il croit que des
forces de l'ordre ont préjugé contre les
minorités et pc c'est une insulte
profondes aux hommes et aux femmes au
lycée policière par tous et chacun
chacune qui revêt l'uniforme le présente
en fait moi nous sommes à vos côtés
c'est remarquable que deux camps le
sénateur team scott a essayé d'adopter
un projet de loi sur la réforme
policière a regroupé les démocrates et
républicains madame la sénatrice vous
avez quitté la pièce est ensuite le fait
de l'obstruction sur le parquet du sénat
qu'à faire beaucoup plus de ressources
pour la police on n'a pas à choisir
entre le succès pour les policiers et le
souss et à offrir
voisins et nos voisines afro américaine
avec le président tchèque nous allons
toujours respecté les forces de l'ordre
améliorer l'emploi et égouttés on a des
investissements records et on veut le
choix scolaires pour tous les américains
répondre madame la sénatrice a je ne
vais pas rester là à écouter le
vice-président par rapport à ce que ça
veut dire de renforcer les lois de ce
pays et je suis la seule sur cette scène
qui a tout fait devant le tribunal je
suis la seule sur cette scène qui a
accusé les grandes banques parce que
elles ont pris pour acquis
les propriétaires je suis la seule qui a
travaillé avec les anciens combattants
et la réalité de tout ceci et que nous
parlons d'une élection dans 27 jours et
la semaine dernière le président des
états unis s'est assis devant des
millions d'américains sans pour
rangement condamner les suprémacistes
blancs et c'est pas comme si il n'avait
pas la chance il l'a pas fait et ensuite
il s'est répétée et ensuite quand on a
insisté
il a dit ça on se retire on attend ça
fait parti d'un pattern dedans ne
trompent
il a appelé les mexicains des violeurs
et des criminels et il a mis en oeuvre
une interdiction sera les musulmans à
charles différent lorsque les gens
manifester de façon paisible
il y avait une femme décédée et ensuite
dès supprimés six blancs qui hurlaient
des atrocités et quand on a demandé à
donald trump
il a dit c'était des bonnes personnes
des deux côtés
c'est ça notre présidente des états unis
et le peuple américain vous méritez
mieux
joe biden sera un président qui va
réunir
en pays mais qui reconnaît la beauté de
notre diversité et le fait qu'on laisse
tellement lasse plus de choses en commun
que ce qui nous sépare le vice président
vous donnez une minute pour facile
sourit remercie de cette minute que vous
m'accordez je pense que les gens
n'aiment pas les médias pour la raison
que vous voyez c'est que vous choisissez
bien ce que vous voulez entendre comme
adama le sadi et nous faisons ces
commentaires souvent madame aarhus après
que le président est proche s'est
prononcé qu'il y avait des gens des deux
côtés sur le net dans le débat sur les
mots les mains et l'a dénoncé le ku klux
klan les néonazis et suprémacistes
blancs et il l'a fait à maintes reprises
le fait qu'il ne condamne pas les néo
nazis
le président tient à des petits enfants
juifs son beau fils est juif c'est un
président qui respecte et chérie toute
la diversité américaine
mais vous dites d'avoir été procureur
est d'abord poursuivre personnellement
déjà il faut vraiment que je souligne
ceci quand vous étiez procureur à san
francisco quand vous avez quitté votre
fonction les afro américains avec dix
neuf fois plus de chances d'être accusés
que les espagnols et blanc pour les
cinéphiles monter la disproportion de la
l'incarcération des noirs à californie
vous n'avez rien fait pour la réforme de
la justice pénale à californie vous
n'avez pas lever le doigt pour changer
cela quand vous êtes à washington la
réalité qu'il faut le présentant des
mois nous nous sommes battus pour la
réforme pérenne sur le vice-président
battu pour les choix scola pour tous les
américains ici et il va le faire pour
quatre années supplémentaires
vous savez une question très importante
est la suivante c'est la dernière
question il s'agit de l'élection et y
s'est attaqué à moi j'aimerais avoir le
gazon néo pro seconde parce que je
manque 600 lots d'abord j'étais
procureur général de l'état de la
californie le travail que j'ai fait est
un modèle de ce que la nes
peut faire et ce qu'on va pouvoir faire
avec un président joe biden
nous allons faire ce que cette
administration n'a pas fait donc on va
mettre en place une interdiction sur six
missions des forces de l'ordre
j'aimerais passer au travers de ce que
vous avez déjà parlé de ces éléments
plutôt et j'aimerais qu'on parle des
élections mais j'aimerais parler du lien
entre ce que j'ai déjà fait et ce que je
vais faire avec joe budden ce qui
comprend le fait que j'étais la première
agente à mettre en oeuvre une demande
qu'on allait porter des caméras quand
par l on était les premiers on voulait
faire une formation sur le billet par
les forces de l'ordre parce que oui on
reconnaît qu'un billet implicite existe
monsieur le vice président contrairement
à ce que vous pouvez croire
on a fait le travail on a mis en place
des réformes pour investir dans la
réouverture c'est le travail qu'on a
déjà fait c'est le travail qu'on fera et
encore une fois vous n'allez pas pouvoir
me parler monsieur le vice-président de
mots l'expérience de ce qu'on a fait
pour maintenir la sécurité dans les
communautés et pour une défense et
madame la sénatrice trs tout d'abord
j'aimerais vous poser une question sur
notre dernier sujet le président roms
n'ont jamais voulu s'engager à remettre
le pouvoir dans la paix sont les étapes
que vous et monsieur byden entreprendre
alors je vais vous dire et moi sommes
particulièrement fiers de la coalition
qu'on a créé dans notre campagne on
apprend une des coalitions les plus
profondes
on a l'appui des démocrates mais des
indépendants et de républicains
également sept membres du cabinet de
george w.bush appuie notre étiquette
nous avons l'appui le groupe a cédé mais
king john chick plus de 500 généraux à
la retraite et d'experts et de
conseiller de la sécurité nationale qui
nous appuient et je crois qu'ils le font
parce qu'ils savent que joe biden est
profondément engagé auprès de notre
démocratie
il veut ramener l'intégrité à la maison
blanche donc on croit dans le peuple
américain on croit dans notre démocratie
et suce voici ce que j'ai envie de dire
votez votez tout trouver un plan pour
aller voter allez sur goal.com vous
pouvez également aller sur joe biden le
site web
nous avons sur les vingt-sept prochains
jours le pouvoir de prendre une décision
par rapport à ce qui sera le cours de
notre pays pour les quatre prochaines
années et nous avons ce pouvoir et si on
utilise notre vote
et si on utilise notre voix nous allons
gagner et nous n'allons pas peine nous
allons nous n'allons pas perdre aux gens
de nous miner à notre démocratie
encore une fois la semaine dernière
devant les millions et l'a ouvertement
tenter
d'empêcher le vote joe biden sur cette
même scène parce que clairement donald
trump y est c'est parti peut s'en sortir
joe baguley tout simplement d'y veiller
voter donc je vais répéter d'aubade oui
voici une madame la sénatrice monsieur
le vice-président plusieurs fois le
président thuram ne s'est pas engagé à
effectuer un transfert du pouvoir qui
soit pacifique en tant que
vice-président quel serait votre rôle
qu'est ce que vous feriez
personnellement dans ce conte où je
pense que nous allons gagner cette
élection parce que c'est une partie de
l'establishment
washington joue pour 47 le présent dans
notre chambre a lancé un mouvement
d'américains de tous les horizons et il
est vraiment confiance que les mêmes
américains qui ont offert cette victoire
historique en 2016 et voilà feuille de
route présent nous allons rebate nous
nous avons rebâti les militaires nous
avons rêves vivez l'économie avec les
réductions d'impôts le commerce
équitable
nous avons nommé des conservateurs aux
tribunaux de tous les niveaux et nous
avons été solidaires des polices et des
policières je pense que ce mouvement
d'américains américaine ne fait que
prendre la vitesse quand vous pensez de
accepter le résultat de l'élection
moi je dois vous dire sénatrice votre
parti et mais cela fait trois ans et
demi que vous essayez de regarder de
renverser les résultats de lancer une
élection 2016
quand joe baden et le président des
états unis est ce que le fbi a espionné
sur notre campagne quand lui était
vice-président est documenté rendu
public que l'essayant affaire renvoie au
fbi et documentant que ces allégations
mais sûr nous avons vu l'avalanche de
tout ce que le pays a traversé pendant
trois années lourdes jusqu'à ce que l'on
trouvé qu'ils avaient pas d'obstruction
pas de collusion
histoire la faire classer et la
sénatrice harris vous et vos amis ou
congrès ont essayé de destituer le
président à cause d'un appel
téléphonique
mais voyons donc et maintenant il craint
tenadi que dubaï qui selon elle ne
devrait jamais concédé l'élection alors
moi je pense que nous allons gagner
cette élection
le pressentent rampe et moi nous sommes
tous les jours devant les tribunaux pour
empêcher qu'à menacer dubaï de changer
les règles et à voir tout est possible
et de fraudes électorales avec l'al vote
postal
si nous avons une élection libre et
juste et équitable je sais que nous
allons très lit pour quatre années
supplémentaires
j'ai noté toutes les questions que j'ai
posées mais pour cette dernière question
j'aimerais lire la question de quelqu'un
d'autre
la commission a demandé à des étudiants
de composer des dissertations sur des
questions qu'ils aimeraient vous posez
j'aimerais vous poser la question de
black nick brown
elle est en 8e année à springer ne
demande lorsque je regarde les nouvelles
tout ce que je vois c'est des disputes
entre les démocrates et les républicains
tout ce que je vois c'est des conflits
entre les citoyens
tout ce que je vois c'est deux candidats
qui essayent de ce 5
comment on fait pour s'entendre si vous
ne pouvez pas vous entendre
si vous donnez l'exemple je pense que ça
serait un excellent exemple afin que
nous nous unissions donc je vous donner
quelques minutes pour répondre monsieur
peine ce matin c'est une très bonne
question
j'aimerais te féliciter de participer à
la vie publique de la nation j'ai
commencé à suivre des nouvelles très
jeune s'est tu et en amérique
nous croyons un échange libre et ouvert
dd nous célébrons cela c'est ainsi que
nous avons créé la nation la plus
prospère la plus libre dans l'histoire
du monde
moi j'aimerais te dire que tu pas que ce
que tu vois ton nouvelle est synonyme du
peuple américain
moi je regarde la relation entre madame
ginsberg feu la juge est un dennis kelly
un autre juge la cour suprême
il était aux antipodes à la cour suprême
à gauche l'autre à droite
mais depuis sa mort compris que ces deux
là étaient vraiment deux prochains mixer
les deux familles aux états unis on peut
avoir un débat vigoureux comme avec est
kamal al ce soit et moi mais quand le
débat terminé on se retrouve ensemble
comme américain c'est ce que les gens
font dans les grandes villes comme dans
les petits villages
j'aimerais t'encourager battre nous
allons travailler tous les jours pour
voir vraiment à la hauteur du peuple
américain
on adore une bonne discussion un bon
argument mais on est toujours ensemble à
la fin et on est toujours solidaires les
uns des autres et vice présidente on est
dans le besoin et on a surtout appris
cela cette année avec les difficultés
qu'on a vécu une sénatrice que dernier
voilà quand même d'abord j'adore quand
nos jeunes leaders s'exprime et
j'entends les paroles j'entends vos
paroles bag line votre avenir et d'une
brillance c'est ce point de vue c'est
cette approche qui est un signe de
divers types ça nous aspirer donc ça me
fait revenir à dubaï dont l'une des
raisons pour laquelle j'ai décidé d'être
candidat à la présidence
c'est à cause de la presse charles aux
différentes salles a tellement perturbé
comme nous tous qu'il y avait ce genre
de haine et de division a décidé d'être
candidat à la présidence parce que il a
vu ce que bracken a décrit depuis 4h jo
à une grande réputation de travailler de
vote de façon bien parti
et c'est ce qu'ils comptent faire comme
président joe biden a un historique de
remonter les gens et de lutter en faveur
de la dignité
jo a connu la douleur il a connu la
souffrance il a connu l'amour et donc
brad l'onu quand vous pensez à l'avenir
je crois que l'avenir et d'une brillance
extraordinaire ce sera grâce à votre
leadership et ce sera parce que on lutte
pour la voix de tous et de toutes deux
par le vote et on s'engage dans le
processus le processus électoral vous
avez l'occasion de faire votre travail à
[ __ ] maintenant déterminer l'avenir de
notre pays et notre leadership
merci madame la sénatrice merci monsieur
le vice-président pence
nous aimerions remercier l'université de
l'utah pour son accueil et merci à tous
les américains qui ont regardé le débat
ce soir nous souhaitons un
rétablissement prend au président ainsi
qu'à la première dame et à tous ceux qui
sont atteints le prochain débat et la
semaine prochaine il s'agira d'un débat
qui se tiendra à miami j'espère que vous
soyez serez des nôtres merci et bonne
soirée
un peu plus de 90 minutes d'un débat
beaucoup plus posé pauli